speaking of surreal there's one thing I
have to ask you about which is I believe
you might be the last person on Earth to
work with Marlon Brando and I just have
to ask you about it oh it was it was
wild I I'll go ahead and say it it was
Buck
Wild I'm glad you had the courage to go
ahead with your thought yeah but it was
on like Scary Movie 2 and I remember at
the time they hired him they gave him a
crazy amount of money to do a cameo and
in this movie and then they I think they
ended up not using him cuz he was too
ill is that right yes sir uh so it was
uh Keenan Ivy wayes was the director who
uh I love and uh yeah so when it came in
I was definitely like yo hard pass
because like I don't I don't with
things called scary movie too um right
and like that's not what I'm in this for
mhm and uh you know and I I love Billy I
love Billy free
H I love The Exorcist which they parody
in that one yeah I actually met him and
spent time with him towards the end of
his life cuz he wanted me to be uh May
West and uh oh biopic that I of course
yeah um but I think originally it was B
Midler that's how name drop so uh just
like you have to take a pause and hit
him with the last name MH and uh I just
call her be but whatever you do yeah you
don't call her the the Divine miss m no
just B yeah well and Wait no that's
Barack Obama oh how many bees
you have in your
phone do you play the spelling bee and
Dallas Howard what's that you call her a
lot just in that redhead Club but I'm
not on the thread I'm not in you were on
the thread but you won't answer yeah um
so anyway uh yeah it was um like yeah
you don't want to with
Linda Blair Billy frein that's
nuts uh and then they were like and
Marlin brand though um is doing it and
uh your your dear heart uh Andy RoR yeah
um and was in it as well yeah but really
Marlin was my way in at the time I was
like I mean you know uh that's working
with brand though so got to do it you
got to be like you know your mother
sucks in Hell H you gota like you
just are you going to do it better than
she did you're not uh you're going to
ruin it but it's BR though and then
shows up uh and he uh yeah was he was
very very old uh and and ill I think
yeah yes and an oxygen tank and uh ear
pieces and I've told this story on your
show live um but um well I guess it's to
tape but uh you
know I'm not involved in the editing
yeah yeah you not that really didn't
need to be qualified but anyway go ahead
and uh if you're not familiar with Conan
work so he uh you
know there was this talk show and I love
how you get to the part where so Brando
shows up now of course Conan used to
tape his show now he'd tape it at 5:30
but it wouldn't air till 12:30 so there
was a lag in which time they could make
short edit you're getting to the best
part of the story and now you're making
it longer to sorry we're all going to
die you want the full
story um as was like you know because of
the breathing and um yeah the bed was
sort of one of the gags was it was like
a low rider that would move all crazy
like a you know Pimp My Ride style uh
which I think he'd never seen uh I don't
even know if it was out yet um yeah um
but uh you know SpaceTime moves in all
kinds of directions it does so anyway he
would keep his hand right on my titt I
think as I was in the Prosthetics um did
not understand that like guy was a real
person at all um and cuz he was so busy
with the oxygen tank and trying to hear
the lines in the bed kind of shaking and
rattling um you're giving him a lot of
credit and uh and you know it's a
despite what my mother said it's a
nice rack you know what I mean
so he know what he was doing and yeah
and I was like wow this is like a
pretty serious Day at the Office
you know what I mean cuz so you're
standing there and you're in all these
Prosthetics marowan brand who doesn't
have long to live has his hand on your
breast for like for like hours you know
what I mean at a time and I'm like like
that's Brando I mean is a
you
know Big Boy Brando yeah yeah you know
um can he breathe not really but you
know is he all there I mean nope uh is
it the sort of acting face off I dreamed
though well it's no on the waterfront
if you look at on the waterfront he's
got his hand on Carl Malden's on Carl
Malden's
breast you they cut they tried to cut
around it yeah they
do and yeah I was like well yeah I guess
I am a Contender after all and
so on uh so I was thrilled and delighted
I thought it was pretty special
um and uh yeah then when he dropped out
of the film the next day um due to his
health and like I think he died like 3
weeks later he died very shortly
afterwards yeah I may be I'm
the I don't want to make it about me but
um you know it's I maybe the last person
that he felt up I don't want to assume
that he was kind of it's like it's not a
big deal it's just sort of like yeah
pretty much Brandon and I banged it out
hardcore you know what I mean like and
three weeks later he died and yeah that
was the last time that he could
manage it and uh then then and then the
next day they brought brought in James
Woods mhm and yeah this is how every
story
ends and then they brought in James
Woods so Godfather four yeah
and and uh he was less of a charmer
uh in the makeup less of a charmer than
the man on
oxygen whose hand is on your breast for
six
days cuz he was like yeah you know I can
tell even with the makeup you're a
spinner
right no no no no no yeah yeah and that
was I thought I mean less sexy uh than
uh you know Brando who's just
oxygen you know I mean pumping and
oxygen it was crazy uh no that didn't
happen and um but yeah the James Woods
one was like oh that's weird but I
think James Wood is a great
actor uh despite the fact that he's a
uh Republican U you know psychopath sort
of um I don't know you know was hitting
on me as a teenager and full monster
makeup uh I
mean pretty
specific a it's a crazy move dude uh he
has a type yeah I guess he does and uh
but my God Sergio Leon's Once Upon a
Time in America you know and multiple
truth
hold you see all facets of The Human
Condition is what you're saying I'm just
saying you see the high and the low I
mean he's a that guy's a great
great actor MH and I don't know what the
Brando was up to but it was nothing
to kosher himself I mean Len
Mar Last Tango I mean him and baluchi a
the shinanigans they're getting
into you don't call that Shenanigans oh
you call it rape I see uh
yeah I mean that poor chick
never recovered from that picture did
she um but it's a you know it's a real
buttery scene
so and multiple truths you know there
are multiple truths yeah there are many
multiple truths and in a way it's like
are they Time Crimes or what because I
think that uh just uh raping and abusing
women throughout history has been uh you
know for uh reasons that are very
obscure and uh Mercurial um conceptually
and morally would just sort of AFF a
life and uh I don't know I'm I'm just
riffing like Miles Davis might yeah I'm
uh I'm I'm I'm just I don't know that's
for you because you brought up I think
75 different incredibly heavy topics but
uh I don't and I of course I don't have
an answer for any of it other than I
mean
uh that I think what comes to mind is me
thinking about
you going through all this without
functioning parents being really young
and figuring it out and you've come out
of it on the other side and
you're a remarkably I think uh
intelligent person who's also non you
there's a complete lack of judgment
you're not judging people you're not
you've been through a lot you've been I
feel like you've been through 50
lifetimes of Madness but you
are very even keeled and you're you keep
bringing up this concept that many
things are true some that that someone
can be a monster but they can also be a
brilliant artist and then you you see
all this three four dimensionality to it
which I think is pretty amazing that you
can look at it all that way yeah cuz I
think we live in a time where people
just want to hear is was someone good or
was someone bad yeah it's a bummer and
it doesn't work that way nope yeah
yep but that said I'd like to end on I
think I'm good very good and I mean
perfect that's not the takeaway from
this I mean perfect in every way and
there's no like layers hard
disagree